the last thing I would have imagined
being a professional that's obsessed
about code for so long is that AI in
2023 could be replacing my job that AI
can write code and program better than
human beings it won't replace jobs but
it will I think augment our cognition in
a way that I still think most people do
not fully understand and what's really
fascinating is that this most
complex technical jobs are the ones that
are being most profoundly
effective all right guys bang bang I've
got Geo here with me uh I thought a
great place to start the conversation is
in the depths of all the controversy uh
AI is here it's accelerating uh and
there's a lot of people who think it is
going to replace all human jobs humans
are going to have nothing to do all day
it's going to make this horrible
dystopia do you agree with that or is it
actually something that's going to
create more jobs over
time I think there's a mixed uh there's
a healthy mix of both I'll give you my
own
perspective I've been a front-end
engineer that's the software engineer
that focuses on the the parts of the
software that touches the user
experience the things that the people
see when they open up a website and they
open up an application and I've been
doing that for 20
years since I was like 10 years old in
Argentina I taught myself how to code
and the last thing I would have imagined
being a professional that's obsessed
about code for so long is that AIS in
2023 could be replacing my job that AIS
can write code and program better than
human beings so the the short answer is
it won't replace jobs it will replace
some jobs but it will I think augment
our cognition in a way that I still
think most people do not fully
understand um it's one of those things
where like you have to use this AIS in
order to truly you have to use them at
work you have to use them as these
co-pilots of everything you do in order
to like really understand the
implications that they're going to have
for jobs and what's really fascinating
is that this most
complex technical jobs are the ones that
are being most profoundly affected so it
almost seems like for the average
person that uh like imagine like blue
collar jobs right the impact there
doesn't seem to be as obvious to me yet
as it is for even my own job which is so
Technical and and uh and in many ways
creative but again like my my whole
thing has always been I'm a techno
Optimist and I believe that anytime we
have new tools that massively amplify
our ability and our cognition we end up
creating more jobs and and a better
prospects for everybody I think that's a
great way to look at the world and you
know we probably look at it very similar
in terms of like it gets better over
time not worse for most people on the
planet um but the path there or the
structure of the technology is also
hotly debated and so right now there's a
big debate between closed source and
open source uh when it comes to
artificial intelligence how do you all
think about that and what are the maybe
the pros and cons of each
approach yeah I'll give you a very quick
framework that I use to understand open
source versus closed Source in the short
term when there is new technology there
there seems like there's an huge
opportunity for large companies to move
really fast and put all their weight
behind proprietary
Solutions so way back in the day uh the
way that the entire Internet run it was
in proprietary software if you look at
how the internet runs today how cloud
services run today the vast majority of
it runs on open source software open
source wins over the long hole in the
beginning it's always the proprietary
solutions that move fast so obviously
today when you look at AI things like
open Ai and proprietary models clearly
better just more intelligence more
intelligent better integrated they're
moving really fast there's a lot of
investment going on the open source
models are not so intelligent yet
they're not so powerful yet but to me
this Rhymes a lot with what I've seen in
my past where for example the Advent of
Linux as a competitor to Windows
especially in the data center and in the
cloud in the beginning not so good when
uh a lot of people don't know this but
when Linux first came out which is this
open source operating system the creator
of Linux introduced it as he called it a
toy he emailed this mailing list and he
said I'm introducing this new operating
system it's kind of a toy I'm here out
here researching at the University of
Helsinki and then what happened was it
just gained this momentum and this
massive ecosystem and community of
people that were pushing it so on one
hand I tell you like the very first
thing I think about is never write off
open source um it's a way of people to
collaborate at massive scale it's a way
for people to exchange ideas it's a way
for companies to do business development
without people being involved in meeting
rooms uh now there's a question of
safety and Alignment right and that's
the one that is most controversial these
days because folks are arguing well this
AI it can become this super intelligence
that could destroy the Earth is best if
they're heavily regulated and if they're
you know if there's maybe two or three
proprietary ones then the government can
like wrap their hands around wrap their
arms around them however the the counter
argument of that is that without open
source it's just hard for the entire of
the world to be monitoring the the
evolution of the technology and ensuring
its safe deployment so on in that sense
I'm actually uh almost a contrarian in
that I really do not believe that AIS in
their current form and in the current
architectures that we're seeing will
pose an existential threat to humanity I
think any new technology that comes out
has the potential for misuse even email
right like I think this example has been
shared a bunch but I still get spam from
a Nigerian prince that wants to donate
the entirety of their Fortune to me and
like oh cool like I here's my bank
account details right um the same is
going to happen with AI so there's going
to be a bunch of people that are going
to misuse the heck out of it for eel
intentions uh I do not believe that it's
on the scale of a nuclear weapon I think
folks that are arguing for that either
are misunderstanding the technology or
perhaps in a more tin foil haton at try
to secure regulatory capture so if if
you look at open source versus
proprietary from that point of view open
source just allows for more scrutiny
everybody can read the code everyone can
read the changes to the code so there's
there's significant benefits I think to
the open source approach there as well
now when we start to see open source or
closed Source some small companies
startups are trying both some big
companies are trying both we' obviously
seen you know Facebook take a very
specific step versus maybe other
companies um how do you think about
value acrel are the startups better
positioned to kind of capitalize on this
AI wave where normally an Innovative
technology is used by the small
companies to move quickly and kind of
take on the incumbents or actually in
this case are the incumbents better
positioned to just simply incorporate it
like maybe we saw with Adobe and you
know the joke being that some of these
incumbents killed thousands of startups
with a single announcement how do you
think about the the balance thing I
think startups will definitely benefit
in a very specific way which is now that
AI is here in democratized for every
Builder on the planet what are the new
disruption opportunities that are unique
to having AI as part of your design tool
meaning before AI you couldn't conceive
certain kinds of software I'll give you
an example at versel we're creating a
tool called
vzer it allows people to create software
interfaces by just using English so you
go to v.d and you say I want a UI I'm
Anthony Pomano I want the UI to
distribute my podcasts on the left hand
side please put in list of podcasts and
a buy button and on the center please
put all my historical podcast archives
and it will just give you a new UI
specifically for you at that
moment now when you go to this website
you realize that it's extremely simple
all it has is this input in the middle
of the screen there's no tools there's
no toolbars there's no icons there's
almost nothing so that's a disruption
opportunity that is start us to
represent is that a lot of the
incumbents have been accumulating
software in complexity and tools and
pixels on screens for decades and
they've become addicted to them and
they're customer customers have become
addicted to them now there could be a
scrappy twers startup in a garage in San
Francisco although there's not a ton of
garages but they're in some uh like a
Tokyo style Hotel capsule in San
Francisco and they're scheming the
creation of a software that because it
uses AI is completely disruptive to that
addiction that the incumbent has now
here's where it gets complicated the
flip side is also true it might turn out
that for certain categories of software
the incumbent just needs to add the AI
they don't need to redesign anything
they don't have to rethink anything you
just add the AI and turn on the money
printer because people the demand that
we're seeing at verell right now for AI
products is like nothing I've seen ever
since the uh the iPhone came out
consumers want to buy this AI product so
the fact that it benefits incumbents
cannot be um understated uh but I do
think that startups are are are uh the
right startups will definitely um win
big in this in this wave now what are
the areas you think are most overhyped
and then maybe what are the areas that
don't get enough attention yet but
you're watching and think could be very
big um kind of counter to the public
narrative at the moment I think
overhyped but I'll caveat this by saying
that I think the excitement is is is
there for a good reason is Agents so the
idea that you launch this entity in into
the world and it'll do stuff I think
it's extremely exciting because you can
do it and and before we couldn't before
the arrival of large language models me
as a programmer I couldn't create this
autonomous intelligence that that things
and reads back the answer from the from
the outside world and then makes another
decision and so on though it is really
exciting but the fact that any idea that
leaves the human out of the loop
is really today fraud with Peril I think
and we have to reexamine our priors
there however when I see AI that is
augmenting the individual and this goes
back to why I think this is going to be
so positive for jobs and
productivity all of the things that are
working and I would argue are even
underrated are the things that are in
the loop with the human and are
augmenting us and giving us feedback and
giving us ideas and so on and so forth
so for example underhyped is the fact
that programmers are now seeing
increasing percentage of the code that
they output be generated by AI as I
mentioned earlier like I could have
never anticipated that was going to be
the case because programming is really
difficult so just think about what that
does for folks coming into the industry
folks that want to learn programming for
the first time today now the AI cannot
just teach how a code it can be there
reading everything you write and give
you ideas for how to improve it so I
think any idea that gives that human the
the context and the ideas and then so
think of it as a the human is still the
creative
director and they're sourcing ideas from
a team of AIS that's what the future
looks like this morning open AI
announced
gpts basically the fact that you're not
going to have just one AI by but
multiple I think this is a very profound
and underrated thing that's going to
happen there are a lot of companies are
saying we're not just going to build one
chatbot we're going to build multiple
the reason for this is that anytime you
need a problem to be solved you
typically go to Specialists right if
your tooth aches you go to the dentist
if your if your back aches you go to the
chiropractor so I think what's going to
happen is very similar and this is why I
think once again incumbents like meta
and WhatsApp are really well positioned
because and this is why they're
investing so much in AI is that WhatsApp
in the future might be a hybrid of
talking to people and talking to
specialist AIS same is going to happen
to chat gbt I think companies are going
to be building their own specialist AIS
I'm seeing now in Silicon Valley a lot
of companies are deploying specialized
chat assistance to train their
Salesforce I just heard about a company
that is a cust of verel that is
providing chatbots specifically to train
large numbers of salespeople what is the
biggest hurdle that organizations face
when they have a huge Salesforce how do
you enable them how do you train them
how do you make sure they're saying the
right things and the same things to
prospects they're saying their correct
things well what are you going to need
there a specialist assistant that knows
your product really well and how to sell
it that is different from my typical
interaction with chbt we like I'm asking
for or some fact about about
Wikipedia so I do think that there's
going to be an explosion in this domain
specific AIS that are conversational and
provided by different companies and tied
to different data sets um and that's
very underrated I think what's the role
of government or regulation in the
development all of this we're talking
about this amazing New Frontier and it's
obvious that there's going to be this
explosion of innovation and kind of
economic uh you know production
the government obviously is very
interested and some of it's coming from
the industry itself saying hey wait a
second we might have you know the next
atomic bomb other people being like hey
idiots you know no we don't uh and so
how do you see them playing into it yeah
I think right now based on what I'm
hearing from my peers in Silicon Valley
there's a fear that they're over
indexing on this is a nuclear bomb I
think that maybe the better way to think
about it is that it's nuclear power and
that we should be not fearful of it of
course there has to be safety protocols
and thresholds around it is a very
powerful thing and and if if
miscalibrated just like a nuclear power
plant it can lead to
damage however just like nuclear power
the risks are typically overstated we
become fearful of things that we do not
understand
deeply but just think about the upset of
every person being able to create with
AI of being able to create their new
businesses as AI first businesses that's
what I think the role of government
should be which of course is a
government that would prioritize freedom
of Enterprise and freedom of access and
freedom of speech right so I do think
that uh if if again if I were to to make
the determination here would be hey all
of our startups need to be able to
access these tools all of our small
businesses all of our individuals of
course we must protect people we must
protect the average citizen have this
fun anecdote of um one of the uh
investors in versel is a major firm that
invests in Silicon Valley companies that
want to have a presence in Japan Japan
for many verticals is the second largest
software buying Market in the world
Japan is a country that loves Innovation
they're early adopters of all software
we have all this exciting communities of
Engineers that love the versel platform
in Japan so I went to visit and one of
the things that the ministry of
Technology was talking about was the
fear of how voice
AI could would become very prevalent to
attack the elderly population of Japan
they already victims to this um
basically scams where like they get
phone calls hey it's your nephew Anthony
or is your grandson I need money wired
now think about how easy it is and and
opena I also made an announcement this
morning and there's Technologies like 11
Labs where you can just clone anybody's
voice I don't know if you've seen this
but there is like even AI music where
Kanye s Rebecca Black Friday uh and it's
just perfect so imagine the potential
for using that and abusing that power to
make phone calls on autopilot and
especially for like the older population
what it could do to their their
financial wellbeing so I do think that
at deployed at Mass scale these AI
systems are are dangerous but again this
is very similar to the email example I
gave earlier any technology at scale
there's going to be bad actors that find
ways to abuse it and misuse it but we
cannot throw the baby at with bath water
now one of the areas that I know you've
got a lot of experience with you
mentioned earlier is around this uh kind
of front-end UI and you spent years
maybe Decades of your life becoming very
good at it and understanding all the
intricacies and and essentially building
expertise now I can go to many of these
different products and with a couple of
words almost as if I was speaking
caveman English all of a sudden get a UI
and maybe it's not perfect but you can
see see that the the you know kind of
direction that we are headed here it is
going to get very very good um on one
hand it kind of just replaced you know
15 20 years of your life and and the
work that you did on the other hand it
would free you up now to not have to go
and and do the work and so how do you
think about generative Ai and and kind
of these UI front ends maybe as like one
area where it's very clear the machines
are probably going to be just as good if
not better than the human at some point
in the near future this episode is
brought to you by cal.com what what do I
have in common with Chad Hurley from
YouTube Toby from Shopify and Alexis
from 776 and the co-founder of Reddit we
all use cal.com instead of cly and we
are all early investors as well cal.com
is leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for lead
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open-source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an
open-source tool that allows you to Take
Back Control of your calendar be
efficient when scheduling and make sure
that no one can steal your
time yeah I think being in silon Valley
and having been here for 10 years uh one
of the lessons for me is that technology
is always accelerating and you must be
able to disrupt yourself so we built
verell as the frontend cloud we want to
make it really easy for businesses to
create the fastest websites in the
planet we have customers like Under
Armour Pinterest Unity they host
incredible user interfaces on versel but
what I hear from this business is that
they're always looking to stream line
speed up reduce costs and just become
more efficient and there's a once in A-
lifetime opportunity for versel to say
we are going to help AI make you more
efficient we're going to help you
generate more applications we're going
to help you speed up those
applications and we're going to provide
you that technology so that's what to me
the AI opport represents today as
opposed to saying okay yeah I'm just
watching from the sidelines let's see
what happens with that AI thing I think
every business on the planet must become
an AI infused AI first business and
that's true for tech companies that have
been around for not as long as for
example like versell has been around for
only eight years but it's also true for
the business have been around for a 100
right uh when I was in Europe I was
meeting with the heads of companies like
Airbus and frankly you know the there's
this sense of like there's fear in some
on some level right like I like can you
espe with everything you hear around AI
safety like what do you do with this do
you just watch it because it's you know
it's somewhat dangerous do you embrace
it do you prototype with it so my My
Philosophy has been just like there was
an opportunity for cloud providers to
accelerate the adoption of the internet
and give you your first.com there's
going to be an opportunity for companies
like versell to give you the opportunity
to have your first AI product and right
now our best uh hypothesis is developers
are spending a lot of time carving each
pixel of our UI there's this famous meme
of like making things Pixel Perfect
there's a designer that conceives the
idea then there's a developer that
implements it and your point that almost
feels like translation I don't know if
you remember when Google translate came
out me being a native Spanish speaker I
couldn't believe just how good it was at
translating Spanish from English but
once upon a time people believed that
translation was the job of a human being
and that computers were never going to
get us
good I think we're going to see the same
with design and
implementation there's a perception even
in Engineers the best Engineers that I
know that
software is a thing that you first
design with pixels and then that someone
translates into working software what if
that translation could be just done by
Ai and that's what we're doing with this
product vzero and and so far it's been
astonishing to me I'll give you a quick
anecdote I use our own platform for sale
to create my own personal website rou
g.com and I designed it with my skills
point I accumulated over 20
years and then I went went to vzer and I
asked it to create my blog and I gave it
the creative Direction said okay make
the background more gray make the design
more minimalistic use this other kind of
font and I was able to replicate what I
had created in just a couple hours but
here's the kicker the code that It
produced was better than the code that I
wrote by hand and I can give you an
objective fact for it it was able to
make it more accessible for visually
impaired or any other kind of user that
needs an assistive device it was a thing
that I was just not an expert in I was
not an expert in accessibility the AI
created something that was goodlooking
and more accessible to more people so
that that was when I had my first
Epiphany with like holy crap AI quote
unquote will take my job but in reality
it will just make my job more
awesome part of what's interesting and
I'm looking at the website right now is
um this idea of uh most people think of
generative AI as like the first
generation right like hey I gave it
instructions it generated kind of the
initial um you know draft if you will
the part that is more interesting to me
is the speed at which you can iterate
and improve that design So when you say
hey make the background you know more
gray do this do that whatever you could
spend minutes hours days depending on
what the product is ETC iterating Now by
simply just typing words it's almost
like you're delegating to someone else
hey go do this and come back when you're
done but it's happening now seconds and
so the iteration speed feels like a part
that is underd discussed but quite
powerful and and even with just your
personal website you're kind of seeing
that as well it's such a great point
it's like writing a wave right when we
set out to create v0 we actually created
it under the principle that AI itself is
just getting better every week so for
example when I when we first created
this the most intelligent AI model we
could use was pretty slow guess what by
the way this product came out three
months ago we on boarded 100,000
Engineers to the product so far today
the same AI model just became faster so
I actually didn't have a ton of
technical knowledge to back the
assumption that the AI was get get fast
I I thought I think we're writing the
right wave right now I think this AI is
just getting exponentially better and it
makes sense to make an investment in
that under that principle alone it
actually reminds me of this awesome
interiew
that everyone should look up to they ask
Jeff bessos why he's creating
Amazon and why he chose books and he
doesn't answer that he loved books or
some awesome story about like his
grandfather's dying wish was to like
make books more accessible you know he
says the internet is coming and I know
that it's going to empower things that
are just not possible in the real world
for example in the real world it's not
possible to have a single bookstore with
more than like 10,000 items in the in
the bookstore it's just not not enough
space so the internet was going to
create a once in a lifetime opportunity
for a business to exist that has more
inventory that can physically fit in the
real world AI is very similar it's going
to create things that are just
impossible and the proof point is just
okay what product can I create that fits
into the into that wave into that
transformation and then it'll expand
into more categories
so that's where I I get my insight of
okay I think what we're seeing okay
front end is being generated by
AI law will be accelerated by AI finance
will be accelerated by AI I just heard
of a Bloomberg terminal that you speak
to in natural language instead of saying
instead of pointing and clicking to find
your stock of choice and look at the
market capitalization you can just say
please plot Tesla's market cap and
contrast it with uh vehicle production
output according to to what you've
indexed of the earning called
transcripts that such a thing can be
created today it's it's was created on
the versel platform it's called fin
tool.com that's going to disrupt Finance
you're going to have all this
verticalized disruptions of a lot of
existing businesses predicated on this
incredible and accelerating AI
capability now for cell itself um
front-end as a service front-end Cloud
there's a couple different ways that
either you guys describe it or other
people would talk about it um it's this
very unique technology where you're
separating the back end and the front
end and you're allowing for things like
uh uh this kind of vzero but but other
uh capabilities talk a little bit just
in terms of like how do you think about
the business today and then what is the
next 12 to 24 months look like in terms
of the product road map and how you guys
think you can kind of really go from
those 100,000 uh developers that you
sign up very quickly to eventually
millions and millions across all the
different products that you have yeah so
our mission is to enable the world to
create the best products period so if
you look at the average product
experience on the interet they it
actually kind of sucks and and outside
of maybe three companies let's just say
that they're called Google Amazon meta
the average in experience is pretty
poor it uh the the the thing you find a
lot is during Black Friday your favorite
e-commerce goes
down uh Taylor Swift announces a new
tour and the ticketing website goes down
slow clunky gives you errors you just
hate it and it's amazing right because
we live in the Golden Era of technology
that like why is that why is there such
a separation between like there's almost
like two classes the upper class the
three or four companies that kick
started the internet Revolution and then
the middle class everybody on the
internet that wants to create great
freaking products but they don't have
the platform to do so and that's what
versel enables for the world so we're
operating at a very significant scale
already we have like tens of billions of
requests that we serve each week on the
platform we host websites like under
armor.com as I mentioned we host um some
of the who's who of the AI Revolution
open AI themselves that are customer
over sell so the key thing is if you
want to create a fast Dynamic web
application or website you come to
versel now this comes with a caveat if
it's just something very small where
like it's say your your own personal
website or things like that that's not
really where versel shines today we we
tailored a very sophisticated use cases
of the internet like I said we we try to
bridge that gap between the brick and
mortar that has existed for a 100 years
and cannot compete with Amazon we help
them do
that when you look at Ai and the boom
there's always the thought process you
can go search for the gold or you could
sell the pcks and the shovels to the
gold miners it feels very much like you
guys are doing the ladder does that also
position you to eventually vertically
integrate and go do some of these other
things that obviously are are use cases
or is that a distraction and and kind of
staying with the pcks and the shovels
and and kind of where you guys are
playing now is actually the better
strategy yeah I I like this idea so to
to explain why it's called front end so
there's always an interface that a
person is interested in in in exchanging
data with so like for example when you
go to Chad gbd and you go to chad.
open.com
that's built with the technology and
framework that we create is called
nexas and that's kind of the the place
where you experience the technology but
behind that there's a lot of
sophisticated technology as well that's
called the back end of an
application so the world that we
envision is one where you know the bet
that we're making is that what really
matters the most to every citizen of the
world is that experience that they
receive and versel exists to make those
experience is awesome fast personalized
unique to each person on the planet and
we facilitate businesses to create those
awesome experiences now we're also in a
very interested position to your point
about we can connect all the services
that exist in the cloud so think of as
turning each capability whether it's AI
payments product recommendations all the
things that you would want to include in
your applications we can turn them into
Lego bricks that people can really
easily slot in into our Cloud so instead
of trying to compete in every Dimension
we think of ourselves as aggregating
this Global Marketplace of ideas
products and services so that people can
create and kind of the aspiration here
is that you know a lot of people should
probably switch away from just pure
consumption to being able to create and
publish great ideas on the internet and
I think over the past few decades we've
we've over indexed a bit on things that
take Tor to consumption so like when you
think about the Tik toks the Instagrams
I think there's probably an entire
generation that could have still they
could instead been creating products and
if we can lower the barri to entry to
those people to create products I think
we're we're going to end up with with a
with a much better
World you've been working on this for a
while my last question for you is what
is the most surprising thing that you
have experienced uh or the thing you
didn't
anticipate over those
years I think just how fast things
accelerate when when you as you get it
bigger uh so in some ways like it feels
like you know I can't believe that we
have a 450 person organization where it
used to be literally just me in an
apartment in San
Francisco the global impact that
technology can have is the thing that
astonishes me uh for example when coid
happened I went to the airport I need to
get a test to go to my my take my flight
Japan both
coid applications that I had to go
through were built in our platform the
one where I could scan the QR code to
get the the test and then I actually got
the wrong test by the way because
apparently Japan required another kind
of Co test so I had to go to another
kind of clinic in the airport also a
versel application I was astonished and
obviously in some ways I should have you
know eat my own dog food I created this
platform so that people could create
application so fast the pandemic hit and
how do you create a fast application to
give people digital appointments for
getting Co tests and vaccines and so on
it ended up we became a a standard
platform for creating that kind of
application when web 3 and crypto
happened we create we became the
standard platform for creating web 3 and
nft marketplaces we still support some
of the largest in the world like openc
Etc now when AI happened we once again
we've provided the plat for folks to
create these AI
Innovations um so that that was
certainly unexpected in the sense of um
if you work hard and long enough and
magical things can happen and they tend
to grow faster than you can imagine it's
also been stressful to be honest like
it's infrastructure on the internet at
that kind of scale it's amazing because
like you you visit this offices in San
Francisco and like I show you versel and
you're like oh wow it's it's not that
many people the impact that it
represents on the world the amount of
traffic that we support and all of that
is incredibly sizable um and yeah so
there's there's a lot of pressure
there's a lot of attacks on the network
for example there's a lot of Bad actors
that were fighting every day and
mitigating attacks on behalf of our
customers so I always tell people
especially Aspire entrepreneurs so that
they know what they're getting into when
you open up a service like this to the
public Internet it's a freaking
Zoo you get everything you get all the
good and you get to see pretty nasty
things about the internet especially
when you're so Diversified across so
many vertical um so I I got to
experience the dark side of the internet
especially now with AI it happened again
I got interviewed about this recently so
there are a lot of bots and Bad actors
trying to find AI applications and
misuse them and try to extract the
intelligence which is really expensive
each time you make an API call to use
one of these large language models it's
very expensive so there are a lot of Bad
actors that are trying to basically
leech your AI resources that you
embedded in your product so there's all
these new categories of attacks and
threats that we have to fight on behalf
of our customers I would have never
expected the size and volume of that and
it's it's awesome and it's a privilege
to be serving the internet and on that
basis but it's kind of hard for folks to
relate to what that's like uh when
you're just enjoying the internet from
your from your from your couch
I could talk to you forever uh where can
we send people to find you on the
internet or if they want to follow along
they want to ask questions where where's
a great place to send them yeah so um I
I'm very active on on X uh formerly know
Twitter so rou G um the versell platform
is on ver.com we have a bunch of
templates that people can and companies
can use to uh to deploy applications uh
and learn and and then if you want to
get started building with AI and and
perhaps you you're not an expert in
front end but you have ideas go to vz.
deev to check out our generative UI
product awesome cam thank you so much
for the time I learned a lot today I
think other people will as well we'll
definitely do it again in the future
thank you Anthony